hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow episode 10 video they did
all the things there are now three
versions of the Black Canary so let's
break it down just careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet
people are gonna be reacting to this for
a while
there were a couple big twists in the
episode but the biggest was probably
like the last couple minutes where they
revealed who is going to be the new
Black Canary on the TV show they didn't
say outright but they heavily implied so
I'll try to explain everything and there
is a new round of the injustice giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video it's just for a copy of the game I
mean they really packed it into like
those last couple minutes of that
episode like they want you to know that
there's so much stuff coming in the back
half of the season Stephen Amell was
teasing stuff on Twitter so I'll try to
include some of that in the video too
so let's do top 12 instead of top 10 but
number 12 just picking up in the last
moments of the mid-season finale where
he sees a laurel in the arrow cave this
is just like WTF what the hell are you
doing here and she tries to explain it
but he's very reluctant there was this
big thing in the episode where Oliver
has this policy of trust but verify
Felicity was kind of doing the same
thing from her end of things and most of
us had a pretty good idea of what was
going on like we'd seen the promos we'd
had a lot of theories about which
version of Laurel it was based on what
the producers have said the rules that
they've created for themselves
there aren't a lot of rules in the comic
book world but arrow has like a couple
set rules for itself in one is no more
resurrections which was a nice joke in
the episode number 11 is the crackpot
explanation that she gives to Oliver and
he's very skeptical cuz he's like I was
there I saw everybody you were nowhere
to be found
like he had a vision of her but it was
just sort of like headcanon Laurel it
was like his mind speaking to himself
through his subconscious so she says
that after all that sara went back and
pulled her out of time
she asked Sara to drop her off here my
favorite reaction that Felicity had in
that moment because she's just
immediately like oh my god it's a
miracle this is wonderful but then she's
like wait a minute isn't it a
coincidence that you arrived just after
Oliver's found out that he's murdered
my boyfriend and after the dominators
did this big assault on the planet that
we had to team up for so even if you had
no idea that this is black siren-like
already there like big warning lights
going off in the background but then
number 10 Oliver goes to meet Diggle and
we learn what the plans are going to be
for the back half of the season 1 Diggle
is gonna try and get out the legal way
which is where the district attorney
comes in and Oliver is continuing to
track down the woman quote-unquote the
woman that we actually saw at the end of
the episode they trained him in
prometheus back in Russia
so that's Talia al Ghul so that's gonna
be a big part of the back half of the
season so the teen have some hardcore
stuff in the flashbacks but because of
all the Prometheus stuff that's
happening in present-day that means that
will also see Talia and present-day
eventually number nine was the Bratva
boss that has it out for Oliver he's the
guy that's working with kovar and is
sort of like a corrupt a more corrupt
version of one of his brought for up
brothers so it's sort of like honor
amongst thieves they're kind of like the
Rogues they have a code of honor but
this person is like way worse than that
he's working with Kovar and is trying to
turn all of her in a reverse version of
what Oliver's trying to do with black
siren in present-day
so that kind of teed you off as to what
was going to be happening with black
siren a little bit because Oliver it
wasn't going to change and even though
you wonder about black siren it seems
like she's not going to change either
but there's a whole bunch of black siren
that we have to talk about number eight
was the actual black siren reveal that
was so funny where she's working on the
DNA Ragman comes in and asks her and
makes the joke about you know what about
an evil twin and then the light bulb and
Felicity's head just dings on and she's
like no we actually have those they're
from Earth too she walks in starts using
her sonic cry but then gets away so
number seven they start watching all the
footage they learn how she got out of
the pipeline Prison and we get like the
backstory so she's been locked up in the
pipeline prison at STAR Labs on the
flash for the past year so ever since
she guest-starred at the end of season
two Prometheus got that information
knowing that Laurel is a weak point for
Oliver in the rest of team arrow they
may or may not address it on the flash
sometimes things will happen
on arrow that they'll only address in
minor ways on the flash and vice-versa
so I guess we'll just have to pay
attention next week and find out because
that would be pretty messed up if nobody
mentions anything about black siren this
big person that they had to face last
year just totally broke out and didn't
set any warning bells off number six is
the DEA working diggle's case and it
seemed like they were setting him up to
try and take down the general himself
like he's this hardcore person they
haven't made the reveal about his
character yet so I feel like I want to
say it but just in case you guys don't
know who the character secretly is on
the show but I feel like most of you
know who he is
but it made it sound like he was going
to try and eventually kill the general
they might be teeing that up for later
in the season but the district
attorney's storyline independent of
Diggle is gonna be big in the back half
of the season there's still some big
reveals for his character number five
they catch black siren Oliver still
wants to believe there's good in her
Felicity isn't having it she mostly
turns out to be right in the episode but
Oliver still believes there's like a
little something in there down deep so
he's gonna try and do everything he can
to turn her but they have this really
funny conversation where she talks a
little bit about her version of Oliver
that died 10 years ago they make it
sound like they completely reversed
positions so maybe he's the one that
died on the life raft or he just went
down and drowned his father's the one
that became the green arrow on that
earth after that she moved to Central
City to try and make a new start for
herself
ran into zoom in started down the dark
path became the black siren that you see
today so you could argue that she was
good before Oliver died once he died
that sort of like broke her heart and
sent her down the dark path so that all
goes into what happens to her at the end
of the episode but number three the
funny moment that she has with Felicity
was so great I mean she ends up knocking
her out later so Felicity gets the upper
hand but she just starts taunting
Felicity what happened between you
things don't look so hot do you have a
sister I hear he likes that it's totally
true so she's not lying but she's just
trying to get a rise out of Felicity so
that she can escape
they eventually recapture her and it
seems like they really want to drag her
through the mud like she tries to kill
full
listen even though Oliver's like there
must be some good in you and it seems
like she's gone completely to the dark
side the reason I think they did that
and then had Oliver say you know maybe
there's something still inside of her so
I'm gonna keep her closed in Argos
is so that she can come back next season
and potentially have some Black Canary
versus black siren episode or they can
make her good if they want to in the
future it's really them just putting her
on the Shelf rather than saying she's
always gonna be bad or she's always
gonna be good it just gives them a
couple different options for directions
to take the character down the road
because they are confirmed for season
six I think they'll get a season seven
as well but I think the other reason for
keeping her evil black siren and not
trying to turn her into metahuman black
Canary and put her back on the team it's
just so that Katie Cassidy has a
different character to play in the way
that rip hunter is a different character
this season Tom Cavanagh plays a
different character every season it's
just something more interesting for the
actors to play especially if she's not
going to be a series regular so number
two is that Talia al Ghul reveal so
she's gonna train all of her during
Russia we'll see that during the
flashbacks then she'll get involved with
the Prometheus plot in present-day
because for some reason she trained
Prometheus the same way she trained
Oliver so we'll have to learn about that
relationship in what he was like when he
came to her what kind of things she
taught to Oliver and if you're wondering
about Nyssa she'll probably come back on
the show eventually they could totally
do a Talia versus Nyssa episode but the
actress that plays Nyssa is on a
different TV show so she's not as
available it's kind of like Manu Bennett
Stephen Amell was like Manu please come
back and play when people were like who
do you want to come back everybody wants
Deathstroke to come back in be
Deathstroke but Manu Bennett is a series
regular on a couple other TV shows so
it's just really hard for him to do that
but the number one is the brand new
Black Canary so if you didn't understand
what was happening at the end of the
episode in the bar when she saw Nick's
creamed those dudes at the windows
that's the actress that's going to pick
up the mantle of Black Canary eventually
whatever's gonna happen they'll explain
in the next episode next week how long
that's going to take whether or not
she'll end up wearing laurels old jacket
or she'll have some different costume
the name on the casting description
only reads Tina Boland it's not a name
from the comics so there could be one of
those things where they change it down
the line or it's a fake name but either
way this is the actress who is going to
be fighting with team arrow as a new
vigilante and the Black Canary
eventually you may have also noticed
that she's from Hub City a lot of you
asked that they keep teasing hub City
does that mean that they're gonna do the
question mark guggenheim said they
really want to do the question but i
don't know if they'll fit him in this
season or if it'll be a season 6 thing
but he's like right at the top of the
list of new comic book characters that
they want to do just to address Black
Canary drama that I saw going on during
the episode I know some of you were
complaining about this because it is a
change from the comics that a lot of you
wanted Laurel to be the Black Canary on
Team arrow but just remember they have
two black Canary's on the TV show now
because one stashed away in Argus so
they just have a lot of options going
into next season but obviously the back
half of the season is gonna be crammed
with a whole bunch of Talia new Black
Canary and doubling down on prometheus
stuff so it is gonna get really crazy
really fast but I feel like it was a
pretty great episode I like the action I
love Katie Cassidy coming back to guest
star I don't know how many more episodes
she's gonna be in but because she's in
Argus she might come back at the very
end of the season to help them with
their Prometheus problem because he'll
definitely be around for the rest of the
season what's gonna happen next is they
just made some big announcements about
the flash movie there's some Avengers
spider-man behind the scenes stuff for
infinity war that I want to post and
Marvel is supposed to have some crazy
big announcement that they're doing in
the morning if it turns out to be
something really cool then I'll do a
video for it so those will be the next
couple of videos congratulations to the
new flash ring giveaway winner mister
Jolly Green please private message be on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details there was a new
round that started in this video I'll
just announce the winner the next time I
post a DC video well you guys wait for
that
you can click here for the trailer for
the next episode of the flash and you
can click here for my flash episode
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight